got ex Mallory and Ilana as of all the
boys and all coupled up this means that
you're now both done from the Islanders
they just got dumped via text we have
reached a new level of savage on love
island and it is time to dig into all
the deliciousness this is love after the
island
[Music]
hey sexy beaches welcome to love after
the island here official love island
recap show i'm lauren zima here to spill
all the tropical tea on this
unbelievable
second week of love island airing only
on CBS and CBS all access later on in
the show we have exclusive interviews
with our dearly departed islanders and
the host of ladies like us on podcast
one the stunning Naza mean mandy will be
joining us you don't want to miss it
with me now is the british hunk known
for his chiseled abs and luscious locks
ER Booker is here of love island at UK
season four thank you so much for being
here
pleasure thanks for having me and thanks
for little nice compliment I don't know
if my abs are so loved island ready
anymore did you get love island ready
before you one of the show to an extent
I'd like to think I had abs before but
now you definitely you put the work in
know that you add a few more abs fine
luckily my hairs my hair and it does
what it does yeah okay well we're gonna
talk to you about what it's like to have
been on love island UK watching love
island here in the US but first let's
just talk about that major Wednesday
night moment oh they were trending on
Twitter a top topic Haman and Ilana that
was a heartbreaking goodbye Hobbit when
she said to him do you want to talk I
would like to come on we were shaking
yet you know for me it started off
savage when they got a text you know
because when you get a text it's kind of
like a good thing you know you think
you're going on a date
or I thought oh you know what maybe
they're same maybe one of them is gonna
go but I didn't expect both of them to
go and then when she came out and was
like you want a talk I was like well you
don't really have much talk about now
just go yeah and then when she left she
kissed him he's still chocolate which it
was kind of sweet and I get why she did
it
yeah his girls standing right there and
then he slyly like wiped off I was like
you couldn't write it I wanted to watch
it again in slow motion
what was amazing about her saying let's
talk is that she had stormed off yeah
didn't want to talk to anybody but I
love that you thought maybe there saves
this a bit triggering for you yeah a
little bit you know the anxiety started
build from the toes and slowly come up
but luckily it didn't get too far
because I realized that I'm not on it
anymore kind of a sigh of relief until
this moment right now because we're
about to recap y'all we have put
together a quick montage of your best
moments I'm a young I'm 22 I'm from
London and on the model it just so
happened that Alex was standing there I
didn't see him there it wasn't in a
malicious way it was like any other
girls in hair that you look I feel no no
announces you are there I don't want to
recopy with anyone in here because I'm
into you and I want to make it work
we're just kind of more sexually
attracted to each other than actually
get on so the boy we've decided to dump
is that like wow I'm sweating I can't
believe I went through that you know
it's nice because I had such incredible
experiences in there as well and there
was some ups and downs you can never do
right by everyone in the process like
that so I would imagine people come up
to you and they say give me advice if I
want to go on the show what do you say
to them I say know who you are and don't
try and be anything you're not have fun
with it I wish someone would have just
said you know what don't take it too
seriously too quickly what was it like
for you when you did leave heartbreaking
emotional you know I was upset to leave
but then again I was in there for a
month and it was a long time and I felt
like I had my try in there you know I
was in two couples you know which is
enough for a month and I don't feel like
I found anybody that I connected with
okay let me ask you then biggest mistake
that our love Islanders here in the US
could make as they're trying a couple of
not being honest and I learned that the
hard way if you're gonna couple up with
someone just make sure you're actually
into them and if you are gonna step on
someone's toes do it in a way that you
can respect them but go and get what you
want because you've only got one shot at
it and somebody else is gonna do it to
you so do it respectfully and make it
happen for yourself well you learned a
lot about yourself and now you are
dating someone I am dating someone new
beautiful Delilah Bella fell I'm working
so well I think we get each other you
she's quite a deep person she gets what
I'm about our intenseness and our fire
eNOS is nice and something that seems to
be working for us really well and I love
that love island helped you figure out
how to begin really yes well her sister
watched it and actually said to her like
you should see this guy on love island
and that's how she found out who I was
so if anything love Island in a
roundabout way help me find love I love
ya I love hearing that it's a nice
feeling I've never really felt so well I
have but not like this you are good at
your job I think it's where I am in my
own life that I'm ready for it and so I
don't have my doors closed
you know I'm fully open and fully ready
to enjoy it well Congrats I love again
that Delilah Belle found you through
love everybody no matter what level and
will lead to a love connection for you
yes joining us now to dig in a little
deeper on all the sexy sandy moments of
love island is the host of ladies like
us on podcast one nazaneen-e man tea
hello beautiful come on in Oh
looking gorgeous for love island thank
you so much for being thank you for
having me I'm excited to talk about the
show Wednesday night was juicy I mean
even from the commercial cut waiting to
hear who he was gonna pick oh it was
crazy it was the moment where we're all
shrinking right absolutely Benji but I
think he's gonna pick her he might pick
her you just never knew the suspect I
think we could see the sense though of a
lot of realizing that Yaman wasn't gonna
pick her I felt like we saw her face
slowly I know she just walked out of
there it was just like done over with I
mean right word nothing maybe want to
say goodbye and then she comes out and
brings him back so you're like what is
she gonna do like is this gonna get
crazy
like the powerful woman yeah I mean oh
I'm ready to talk to you so now coming
to David on her own time right I
actually I'm really into that oh yeah
we're gonna talk more about Yaman Ilana
this week we want to focus now on the
comings and goings of the Islanders who
we saw depart starting off with our
first elimination Michael
we spoke to Michael as he headed off of
the island take a look at everything he
had to say leaving love island maybe
this is what's supposed to happen you
know I mean it was it was fun it was
great I met amazing people and I wish
them the best of luck honestly I don't
think I've could have done anything
differently I think I made the right
choice initially but I just don't think
the right choices were in there for me
it is what it is so I'm gonna go back
home now and see my little puppies
thanks ET later Michael seemed a little
down but also not taking much ownership
there he said the right choices weren't
here for me there's a lot of big
personalities and if you're not gonna
showcase your full self from the minute
you walk in there then there's no time
for you lost in the shuffle when you're
there can don't have that huge person
sometimes it's hard that's what you
signed up for so you know step outside
and bring it or that's what's gonna
happen oh Michael you're on video now
you got to talk okay all right then we
had our gorgeous new girls show up
Katrina and Kristen so these gals come
in they shake things up
[Music]
the villa is about to get intense
butterflies in the air look you know I
did not like the kiss between finding a
man I'm here for a reason and my goal is
to find someone Treena I don't know if
our lives ever met but I'd like to
introduce them but I don't like step on
anyone's toes or anything I literally
felt like we could have been there till
the next day just talking talking about
everything you know like he came here
for love and so if he found someone like
good luck for me but it could be by
suicide yeah I could buy another guy you
know so the whole point it's a find the
best connection yeah well there's no
other guys here that you think may be
like you Oh from him yeah oh no but we
are watching Katrina tell Mallory how
well things went with her in Weston with
Mallory's guy knows what is going
through your head when you're watching
Matt can feel the tension through the
screen absolutely I mean she had to have
her shades on in the beginning to hear
this story
I couldn't believe Mallory just sat
there and kind of took it all from her I
mean it's the name of the game all right
they're there to find love so she's
gonna give it and Katrina was given it
she could have sugar-coated it a little
bit and just be like you know sweetness
you know what about but then we wouldn't
have this amazing television show it's
about who the girls look so we get the
reek up Alang ceremony decisions are
made let's take a look at how things
ended up I went a couple up with this
girl because I saw her eyes and I saw
sparkle the girl I want to couple up
with is
Treena no I want to couple up with this
Grove because it just seems like there's
just a natural connection there the girl
I like the couple up with is Kristin and
there she goes
the faces said so much during all that I
mean what Malory she was actually
applauding when Weston picked Katrina
out but you know it's amazing though in
30 minutes she packed her bags and had a
conversation with him
tell me though Naz what you thought of
Yemen's choice should he have gone with
Alanna it's hard to say it's new and
you're just with that person so you you
know you feel the connection more it's
him and Kristin don't crowd that fresh
connection exactly you know it's just
how it goes you're in the moment you're
feeling it and you're like oh my god
this is new and exciting I want to go
with her mmm decided she wanted to have
a breakup conversation she yelled do you
want to talk and here's how I genuinely
was trying to form a deeper connection
at 100%
it just wasn't gelling perfectly for me
there's someone's gonna love the hell
out of you it's just she kind of fits my
life a little bit better I'll be lying
if I said I didn't like you
[Music]
crying about watching an oscar-winning
drama I mean the feelings are so real
yeah I actually have a lot of respect
for Yaman he had a really hard decision
to make the fact that he went into that
room and spoke to her he was really
quite sweet about it and a lot of men
would have ran away from that situation
and not him who stepped in that works
the way she called him in our to
probably gone for a swim but actually it
was a really nice way for them to depart
I think as sad as it was I can't
imagine this happening but if you had
just gotten dumped yes do you call the
guy in for the conversation I am out of
there I'm packing my things I'm gonna
try and pack in 30 minutes and I'm gonna
get out of there
gracefully excuse myself I think we
could see that her lotions were all over
the place because at first she was out
she'd want to talk and she said I do
want to talk she's holding Mallory's
hand as she's leaving I mean it was raw
hey maybe she needed the closure you
know what I mean it happens yeah I
wouldn't have been able to walk out of
there without at least having that final
conversation with someone just for them
to know what I felt for me to know what
they felt and then you put it to bed and
you move on
I still got my dignity I still got a
really nice butt and under voice a buddy
you go go cuz there's a man out there
he's gonna love that she's gonna find
somebody for sure
she's gorgeous and we spoke to both
Alanna and Mallory right after they left
here's what they had to say in that
moment I'm sad I'm really sad leave
everyone I'm sorry I didn't really get a
chance to meet a guy but some great
friends so I feel good I don't have any
regrets and give it my all
little disappointed you know as I leave
my booth got less bullying I was myself
the entire time I got distracted by the
app but it's cool you know next guy I
will not be looking at the app exactly
what they're gonna win this thing like
they're so cute I'm ready for them like
you my friend Ilana learned from love
Island she said don't get distracted by
the athletes you know what I kind of
think with Mallory her sweetness hurt
her because she was such a friend to
everyone she was so oh it's not working
out with us even at the end she's like
Elizabeth Zach they're great my only
regret is not meeting someone so I don't
know we could see how things shake up
but we're seeing the seriousness of the
couple's now we're feeling these real
connections were seeing true heartbreak
and then Winston comes in so Winston an
alum of Big Brother 20 shakes things up
goes for Kira but she kind of stays
strong for cash and then Winston gets a
date with three of our lovely ladies
Katrina you Johnny the first portion
yeah the trainer like obviously if I was
picking she'd be breakfast lunch and
dinner
and maybe a snack
would you join here's a second one sure
and then Carol would you join me Oh
Carol I guess I'm like okay man thanks
I'm just like one of those guys are just
like so well together oh my god you know
he's trying to get you right no it's
obvious he took you for the meal you
know a little snack you're a meal honey
I hopefully at the end of this I mean
it'd be great to like have a girlfriend
I didn't want to come in and like force
that either yeah I'm kind of like
chilling
wanna be myself hang out and if it
happens that's amazing it's not it's
okay Hugh it was a good day who are you
rooting for for me it's like an
Elizabeth it's that fairytale kind of
love that you see on films and and I
like that I'm a sucker for that there
was something about watching them kiss
on that night vision but I loved
watching it Naza who are you I can't say
it I don't know you know there's gonna
be new people shaking it up and I don't
want to make my predictions just yet I
feel like something's gonna happen we
still have so much to see you never know
who can walk in on love island well we
have officially filled our love tank for
this week our special thanks again to at
love island UK superstar al Booker and
the lovely Nazanin Mandy for her
insights listen to NAS ninon her podcast
ladies like us on podcast one and get
ready for her new single coming out soon
July 26 my very first single it's called
forever moon and love Island is a
forevermore it's a forever be sure to
tune into love island five nights a week
only on CBS and if you missed even one
delicious moment you can binge every
single episode on CBS all access CBS com
anywhere you watch CBS join us back here
every Friday as well for a weekly keiki
to discuss all the ins and outs of love
island will have exclusive content from
the islanders themselves celebrity
guests to weigh in on all the tropical
tea and you guys don't forget to
download the official love island app to
slip into summers hottest show from the
comfort of your own home plus when
you're talking about it on social use
the hashtag love Island USA all right
from our cozy Cabana here in California
thank you both again
i'm lauren zima stay cool sexy beaches
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]